ARRIVAL IN THE U.S. SENATE.
>> Laura: MIKE, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
JOINING NOW IS CONGRESSMAN JAMES
COMBER AND DANA WHO RAN AS A
DEMOCRAT IN 2016.
EXPLAIN HOW DEMOCRATS ARE NOT
TRYING TO ALTER THE AMERICAN
ELECTORATE WITH THIS BILL?
>> NO, WHAT THEY ARE TRYING TO
DO IS THE MOST PERSON THING
POSSIBLE.
IMPOWER PEOPLE TO VOTE.
TO HAVE A FUNCTIONING DEMOCRACY
WE NEED PEOPLE TO GO TO THE
BALLOT BOX AND VOTE.
THIS IS ALLOWING PEOPLE TO
REGISTER TO VOTE MORE EASILY.
DECLARING ELECTION DAY A FEDERAL
HOLIDAY.
WE ARE ONE OF THE ONLY
DEMOCRACIES IN THE ENTIRE WORLD
THAT DOES NOT HAVE ELECTION DAY
ON A WEEKEND OR HAVE IT BEING A
NATIONAL HOLIDAY.
>> Laura: WE HAVE AN ELECTION
DAY THAT STRETCHES FOR WEEKS AND
MONTHS.
NOW DID WE SURVIVE AS A
CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLIC.
MY MOTHER WAS A WAITRESS AND MY
DAD GOT TO THE POLLS ONLY 1 DAY.
HOW DID WE FUNCTION BEFORE?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THEY ARE TRYING TO BUILD UPON ON
WHAT THEY DID IN CALIFORNIA WITH
THE BALLOT HARVESTING.
THIS IS NOT THE ANSWER.
PEOPLE ARE EMPOWERED TO VOTE.
IT'S EASY TO VOTE.
SAME DAY VOTER REGISTRATION.
THAT'S A BACK DOOR TO GET MORE
PEOPLE TO VOTE WHO ARE NOT LEGAL
CITIZENS.
THAT'S THEIR GAME PLAN DO BEAT
DONALD TRUMP IN 2020.
WE WON'T LET IT STAND IN THE
HOUSE.
>> Laura: DANA, ANOTHER THING I
AM DISTURBED BY:  WHAT IS
HAPPENING WITH STATES 'RIGHTS?
THIS WOULD SET VOTER I.D. AND
WHETHER FELONS COULD VOTE OR
NOT.
THAT'S A STATE PERROGATIVE.
HOW DO YOU REACT TO THAT?
>> AGAIN, I CAN'T THINK OF
ANYTHING MORE AMERICAN THAN
EMPOWERING OUR CITIZENS TO VOTE.
>> Laura: WHAT IF THEY HAVE NO
DESIRE TO VOTE?
>> THEY DON'T HAVE TO VOTE.
>> Laura: NO, THEY REQUIRE YOU
TO BE REGISTERED.
IT'S YOUR RIGHT AS AN AMERICAN
CITIZEN TO BE LEFT ALONE.
WHY DOES THE GOVERNMENT HAVE THE
RIGHT TO TELL YOU TO REGISTER TO
VOTE?
>> THEY ARE NOT FORCING YOU TO
GO TO THE BALLOT BOX.
>> Laura: THEY ARE FORCING YOU
TO REGISTER.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE SELECTIVE
SERVICE?
WE FORCED EVERYBODY TO REGISTER.
>> Laura: THAT'S AN EMERGENCY
WARTIME PROVISION.
>> NO, EVERYBODY RIGHT NOW.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> Laura: WE HAVE TO MOBILIZE
PEOPLE QUICKLY.
THIS IS NOT MANDATING THAT
SOMEONE AS AN INDIVIDUAL WHO
DOES NOT WANT TO VOTE, HAS NO
DESIRE TO VOTE, SHOULD NOT HAVE
TO BE REGISTERED TO VOTE.
>> YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> DEMOCRATS WANT EVERY
GOVERNMENT FOR EVERYTHING.
>> Laura: LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT
THE DEMOCRATS THINK ABOUT 16
YEARS OLD VOTING?
PEOPLE THINK THIS IS LIKE AN
INTERNET TOTAL HOAX.
THAT'S RIGHT, DEMOCRATS TODAY
VOTED TO SUPPORT THE STATES THAT
WANT TO LOWER THE VOTING AGE TO
16.
DANA?
>> WELL, MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT PROVISION IS NOT MAKE IT IN
THE FINAL BILL.
THERE WAS AN AMENDMENT PROPOSED.
>> Laura: A MAJORITY OF
DEMOCRATS VOTED FOR IT.
>> BUT IT DIDN'T PASS.
IT ALLOWS FOR 16 YEARS OLD TO
PRE-REGISTER TO VOTE.
DON'T WE WANT THEM TO BE READY
TO VOTE AND EXCITED TO VOTE WHEN
THEY TURN 18.
THAT'S A GREAT THING FOR
AMERICAN.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN, ARE YOU
AGAINST THE YOUTH VOTING YOU?
MUST HATE THE YOUTH?
>> WE WANT EVERYONE TO VOTE.
I AM ASTONISHED THE DEMOCRATS
WANT TO RAISE THE AGE OF
AMERICANS TO OWN A GUN OR TO BE
ABLE TO PURCHASE TOBACCO BUT
LOWER THE AGE FOR VOTING.
WE HAVE NOTHING THAT STANDS IN
THE WAY OF YOUNG PEOPLE VOTING
TODAY.
I AM ALL ABOUT MORE PEOPLE
VOTING.
I THINK WE HAVE A GREAT
DEMOCRACY.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE CONTINUALLY
TRYING TO CHANGE THAT TO BENEFIT
THEMSELVES.
>> Laura: DANA, DO YOU THINK
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS SHOULD BE
ALLOWED TO VOTE IN THE U.S.?
SOMEONE HAS BEEN HERE 10 YEARS.
THEY HAVE FRAUDULENT
IDENTIFICATION BUT PAYING TAXES
OUT OF THEIR SALARY.
I AM PLAYING A DEMOCRAT TODAY:
SHOULDN'T THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO
VOTE?
>> I BELIEVE IN A PATH TO
CITIZENSHIP.
ONCE YOU HAVE CITIZENSHIP, I